leaving this hospital until I know
what's wrong with my daughter that is
Jennifer Garner in the new faith-based
drama
miracles from heaven now she was going
through a tough time when she shot this
movie so when we sat down for our
conversation I wanted to know how
important faith has been in her life I
loved in the film
Einstein's quote that got two ways to
live your life you can either see your
life as having no miracles or you can
see your life as being filled with
miracles I've never doubted day in my
life
she has handled her split from husband
Ben Affleck with strength and dignity
and even though her new movie has put
her square in the spotlight during a
painful time Jennifer says it's the
lesson of faith has been her saving
grace this film in itself a miracle for
you it was a very difficult choice
because I I don't typically play the
lead in films it takes too much time
away from my kids and this film I kind
of went to them and said what do you all
think I really felt feel compelled to
tell the story and my daughter's so
sweet she said mom it's really your turn
you will be okay you should do it I was
careful me too Jen plays mom Christy
beam in the film based on a true story
12 year old Kylie Rodgers plays her
daughter Anna who is diagnosed with an
incurable disease it's the real anti
virus
my favorite moments from being on set
favorite moments most of them are
definitely within that because we need a
lot of arts and crafts and a lot of
braiding but through it all Dan's never
lost her sense of humor even playing the
saxophone and telling off-color bedtime
stories in these viral videos I gotta
ask you about the fun of YouTube video
the the bedtime story which I hope you
have not seen young lady near cozy and
warm in your bed my dear now my words
don't see it look I gotta say what
impresses me the most about Jennifer no
matter what she's going through no
matter what she's dealing with her three
children with Ben always come first and
that is my parenting mantra as well I
totally agree